people are trying them the media is
tooting them but scientists say we need
to know more about how they work and
when they can help
this quote comes from the March Stanford
magazine Edition titled falling for
psychedelics
so where's the Hope or is it all hype
well in this video I'll give an overview
to Classic psychedelics with some
essential neuroanatomy and then we'll
look at this recent study that has
identified a possible therapeutic
mechanism that involves activation of
Pathways involved with dendritic growth
as we'll come to conclude studies like
these are imperative for providing a
foundation with which to guide optimal
dosing and to identify individuals who
could benefit from psychedelics and also
the other challenges ahead
so firstly what are psychedelics and why
are people excited about them
psychedelics are molecules that can
affect perception cognition and mood and
produce intense subjective experiences
due to these effects there is much
interest in understanding the
therapeutic potential for treating
Neuropsychiatric disorders such as
anxiety depression and substance abuse
and this has even been employed in
medically supervised psychedelic
assisted therapy in the magazine article
it describes the story of a former
Special Operation Soldier and FBI agent
Paul
who after years of nightmares insomnia
anxiety and depression from recounting
his time in Iraq and Afghanistan
participated in a trial where he took
psilocyburn assisted therapy
after taking the substance Paul
describes his experience as exhausting
it was like he'd been wrestling with
himself for six hours straight but
afterwards there was a load office back
of punishments guilt and self-hatreds he
goes on to say it was not a fun
experience but after I felt so good I
felt free hopeful happy
it is thought that the Psychedelic
induced trip might help the brain
reorganize thought patterns to find to
find new ways of processing anxiety
depression or trauma
says Laura hack an assistant professor
of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences
who treats Veterans of PTSD and
depression
and a few other pilot studies have been
conducted he reported in the New England
Journal of Medicine a phase 2 trial
shows that participants with treatment
resistant depression when given
psilocybin at a single dose of 25
milligrams but not 10 milligrams reduced
depression scores significantly more
than a one milligram dose over a period
of three weeks
but it's both mentioning that 77 of all
participants in the study had adverse
effects ranging from headaches nausea
and dizziness
Solace I've been what Paul took can be
found in more than 100 mushroom species
along with LSD DMT and DOI these are
referred to as the classic psychedelics
one action of these classic psychedelics
is that they combine to a protein
receptor known as the
five-hydroxytryptamine to a receptor or
five H2 ta are for shorts if you take a
look at the chemical structure of these
classic psychedelics you'll notice that
they assemble the compound serotonin
otherwise known as 5-hydroxytryptamine
hence the receptor I just described is
one type of Serotonin receptor
and I say one type because this is just
one out of at least 14 different
serotonin receptors
under the central nervous system
serotonin receptors are found in
different regions of the brain including
the cerebral cortex the outside of the
brain the hypothalamus the hippocampus
and the brainstem and this image here
shows why the serotonin 2A receptors are
localized and so the three chemicals
that we'll focus on for the remainder of
this video
are two psychedelics silosine the one
derived from mushrooms psilocybin DMT
the main psychoactive component of
Ayahuasca a potent hallucinogenic
plant-based brew that has been consumed
for thousands of years by indigenous
people of South America
and good old serotonin
and so if we focus on these three
compounds and I mean really focus on
them it raises an interesting question
these molecules are mimicking serotonin
and we all have serotonin in our bodies
so why are we not all continuously in a
hallucinogenic state
clearly somehow these slight molecular
differences are having an impact but
what and how
well that brings us on to this recent
publication psychedelics promotes
neuroplasticity through the activation
of intracellular 5-h2ta receptors so we
come back to the serotonin to a receptor
which falls under the class of proteins
known as the gpcrs or G protein coupled
receptors these are in my personal
opinion a top tier family of proteins
that's a far-ranging functions but are
united by the fact that they are
embedded in membranes and they have
seven transmembrane domains so that they
have Parts sticking out on both sides of
the membrane this makes gpcrs like the
serotonin 2A receptor good signal
transducers
as many gpcrs are predominantly found at
the cell surface they can transduce a
signal from outside the cell inside
so these three compounds you may think
that potentially due to the similarity
silosin and DMT are antagonists maybe
they're blocking serotonin from binding
the receptor but that's not the case
like serotonin these compounds are also
agonists they cause activation
but the impact of these chemical
differences altered the chemicals
lipoflacity how much it likes lipids or
another way of thinking about it how
easily these chemicals can pass through
the cell membrane without a protein
serotonin is highly polar and so you
cannot easily pass through the cell
membrane but both silosin and DMT
possess extra methylation that makes
them prefer lipids and so they can pass
easily into the cell
and interestingly in the study what they
did was they plotted the lipophilicity
against the psychoplastogenicity and
they could see a positive correlation
hair psychoplastogenesity is defined as
the ability to promote structural
plasticity in the dendrite branching
so this is perhaps the point of the
folio wire to do a little bit of a neuro
101 as neurons receive chemical signals
from neurotransmitters at so-called
dendrites and what they are observing
here is increased branching and spikes
on these dendrites following treatments
such as with DMT as you can see in this
figure here
and so what I'm trying to say is what
they found in a study is that the
psychoplastogenicity correlated better
with the lipophilicity of the chemicals
then the ability of the chemicals to
just activate the serotonin to a
receptor
but how and why why would going across
the membrane impact this Downstream
effects of alternate dendrite growth
well the researchers decided to look at
where are the location of these two a
receptors within the cell
and it turns out in the neurons in the
cortical neurons they're not just at the
cell surface in fact they observed
bright staining within the cortical
neurons and they show you that it
co-localized with other markers within
the cell
suggesting that maybe these serotonin
TWA receptors are also functioning
within the cell as opposed to just at
the cell surface membrane and so to to
test this a bit further what they did
was they blocked or hunts their membrane
passing ability and saw how it influence
the dendrite formation
my favorite part of the study was when
they exploited the fact that serotonin
can't pass through the membrane
and instead genetically altered the
cells such that they express a serotonin
transporter so that the cells could now
take in serotonin and so when they
expressed the serotonin transporter
protein in the neurons and treated with
serotonin it matched the response that
they would see with DMT
so as we can see it's all about location
location
the paper suggests that the
therapeutically relevant mechanism of
action for DMT in silosin involves the
2A receptor which intracellularly
promotes dendritic growth and increases
the spine density of rhetorical cortical
neurons
so I should point out here as well that
these studies are done in Rat neurons
and so to get back to my first question
is this hope or hype well me being The
Optimist that I'd say there is hope but
there are clearly many areas still to
address hence why papers like this
recent one are intriguing because they
can give an insight into the molecular
mechanism as once you know the targets
and how is impacting the cell you can
design or look for more selective
chemicals or chemicals that have
different properties and use it to guide
optimal dosing and identifying
individuals who are likely to respond
positively to psychedelics
so it's also worth pointing out here
that in this paper they primarily
considers the serotonin to a receptor
but another important caveat to consider
is that many if not all psychedelics
also potently activate the closely
related serotonin 2C receptor
and then it's also worth thinking about
the long-term consequences both in terms
of understanding long-term molecular
mechanisms but I meant more long-term
and thinking of standard clinical
application even when telling people I
was making this video I got some looks
when I mentioned the phrase psychedelics
so a big one is public perception and
this interesting commentary suggests
changing the name but for multiple
reasons narrowly defining a drug class
by one set of its effects psychedelic
collards the perception as it being the
only thing that it does an example they
give is antidepressants if someone told
me to take one for a non-psychiatric
condition I might have preconceptions
about it because of the class name
and so this commentary suggests
alternatives to psychedelics as
psychoplastogens or neuroplastogens
anyway besides that there is also the
challenge of actually conducting
clinical trials partly because it's hard
to control for them
that being there might be a strong
placebo effect and in the New England
Journal of Medicine article I gave
earlier the control condition was just
having a lower dose of the Psychedelic
compounds
so clearly there is some reason to be
excited about psychedelic compounds for
treating different disorders but I like
the comment from this magazine article
that today's psychedelic researchers
hope the public will wait a little
longer for science to provide answers
before something bad happens and the
promise of psychedelic therapy slips
once again back underground
the hype around this partly is because
psychedelics could be a quick fix
there are other ways of reducing the
hyper connectivity of brain regions over
time including mindfulness meditation
exercise and antidepressants but what's
unique to psychedelics is how rapidly
such a dramatic change can happen
but it may not be as long as you think
as there is a lot of research going on
at the moment and a lot of momentum as
in the process of making this video
another paper came out showing neural
Imaging following human consumption of
DMT
and what they saw in his paper was that
DMT breaks down the basic networks of
the brain causing them to become less
distinct from each other we also see the
major rhythms of the brain that serve a
largely inhibitory constraining function
breakdown and then concerts brain
activity becomes more entropic or
information rich
but the other thing that I find quite
curious are what are the long-term
responses and changes at the molecular
level
this study suggests epigenetic changes
which as I explained in this video are
heritable marks
so with that I hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to all
my supporters on patreon and thank you
for listening